[Music]
bad information impacts all of us
scams threaten all of our finances
political misinformation undermines our
democracy
when it comes to the coronavirus
pandemic health misinformation
threatens all of our lives
in human history it has never been so
easy to spread misinformation to
millions of people
so rapidly
my name is laura walters i'm a
journalist and
i have been a victim of misinformation
i got a cold call from a new
website looking to publish news content
everything seemed very normal like any
other kind of freelance commission
i wrote the story on chinese influence
in new zealand
and then i literally thought nothing
more of it
and about three or four months later i
got a call
turns out that the fbi had actually
tipped off facebook
this news organisation wasn't a news
organisation at all it was the same
troll farm that meddled in the 2016 u.s
presidential elections
from there it's been a deep dive into
learning about
how our networks are infiltrated to try
and spread misinformation
i could have completely avoided this
situation
if i had applied the scrutiny in the
same way that i do when i'm
investigating a story myself
if i can show how it happened to me
maybe i can help other people avoid it
it's been a
real wild experience for me
you know it's important to remind people
of the dangers of information and the
new ways that people can share
information that present uh risks to all
of us but also the
internet as a means of sharing good
information yes
we're all confronted with more
information than ever which makes it
hard
to tell fact from fiction but at the
same time
fact checkers like us can use the
internet and the reach that we have to
correct the record
quicker than we ever could and directly
to people
you can verify a story in many cases by
simply
typing in the claim that you're not very
sure of
and putting fact check next to it for
example on your
preferred search engine there's a very
good chance that
the the top results will actually take
you to one of the fact checking
organization's website that has already
looked into that claim
fact-checking organizations have looked
into
well over a hundred thousand claims
just when the pandemic started within
one year they've looked at over ten
thousand claims
only related to the pandemic there were
quite a few
stories circulating that were false that
were
offering very simple cues to the disease
such as if you inhale steam and that it
would cure
coronavirus it just seemed completely
illogical
but when people are just overwhelmed by
the amount of information
and they're scared and they're anxious
you know it shows that they can believe
things
it's interesting when we're sort of
anxious we
have on the one hand a need to actively
go out and find information as a way of
explaining um what's going on or even
you know to help keep us safe but at the
same time the research shows we also
experience
paradoxical inability to process
complexity
which altogether means that when we are
anxious we are even more susceptible to
bad information
there are tools online to verify for
example fake images
one of them is google reverse image
search
where you put in an image and search for
that image
it is a really useful way of seeing
where that image originally came from
something like this would be a huge news
story
so if it's not being reported by trusted
news sources and that might be a clue
that it's that it's not actually
true
deep fakes is is a big concern and it's
a growing concern
because it's completely new technology
the wonderful world of deep fakes
ai and vfx in the future that technology
is going to be perfected and then
we would really struggle to tell whether
that video is not what it's meant to be
and so more technology is coming out
that would help curb the spread of
misinformation in the form of plugins
that you could download and attach to
your browser
they could tell you what's less credible
and what's more credible algorithms that
could help the social media platforms
detect automatically and very rapidly
which stories being circulated that are
not true
i'm quite hopeful in our ability to
tackle the spread of
misinformation in the future because
more people are aware of
the issue and because ai technology is
becoming far more effective and powerful
in determining what is credible and what
isn't
and in reducing if not stopping the
spread of that misinformation
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video